i want to look at a very disturbing
video not disturbing in the sense that
it's gory not disturbing in the sense
that there's bad words swears as we
might say
it's disturbing because it is
another one of these examples of how
conspiracy theories rarely live alone in
someone's brain and we talked about this
with dr stephen novella earlier in the
week and we've talked about this with
other experts on conspiratorial thinking
they say well
flat earth it's so benign okay you think
the earth is flat but that's it doesn't
mean well no typically these conspiracy
conspiratorial beliefs come in groups
and an attendee at a chuck grassley town
hall
said
putin's not bad because he's fighting
nazis and what about the ukrainian
biolabs and the pedophilia and there's
deep state corruption in ukraine
and it's emblematic of how it's never
just one conspiracy theory and maybe
just as disturbing
is that chuck grassley doesn't seem to
push back against any of these
take a look at this this is what america
has become
half of america and on what you know
about
bio labs
the financing that putin has stopped
over in ukraine the neo-nazis the nazis
and the
pedophilia that goes on in ukraine by
the way
i i just love that
not only are they often confused by the
conspiracies it's a word salad a pet or
feel it come on guys okay and who's
there stopping it our news doesn't bring
that out do you know anything about that
well you mentioned four things so
on a pedophile that's
i don't know whether there's anything
special about ukraine and pedophile i
but i do know that human trafficking and
not just sex trafficking but human
trafficking for economic slavery
is an internet it's bad in the united
states but it's worse internationally
and so i suppose that there's some of
that in ukraine but i can't say that
it's worse there than other places
and then what did you bring up the bio
labs um
the financing that's he stopped over
there and then the nazi neo-nazis in
ukraine well the financing
hasn't stopped because congress
appropriated in 14 billion
uh seven for humanitarian
for military so
so you uh maybe you just saw on
television that no i don't watch
something
no he's getting his news exclusively
from facebook he doesn't watch tv
that the funding the reply of the bio
or do not
oh it's now deep state i see
is that going back to biden when he was
vice
president be nominal maybe did you know
anything about that
we we've been
i've been briefed on uh
the lab
something that was set up in the uh so
you know chuck grassley is kind of
taking this piece by piece but the
really the problem here is
sir
you've fallen for a package
of of claims
individually each of which is not what
you've been told is there is there
trafficking in ukraine yes there's a
there's a problem with trafficking in
eastern europe but the problem is in
russia as well
and putin's invasion of ukraine is no
more justified because ukraine also has
trafficking
the bio labs thing the bio labs in
ukraine are not unique
they're not particularly pernicious
there's nothing special about them the
us is part of a consortium that funds
research all over the world there's many
labs in europe some of them are in
ukraine deep state well what what are
you talking about
it's almost like there's a um
it's like a starter pack of conspiracy
beliefs where it's like a word salad it
just comes out of them almost like
they've taken some kind of
conspiratorical conspiratorial ayahuasca
and everything is just being come it's
just you can't stop it they're they're
just vomiting it out into a bucket the
way many on ayahuasca do um this is an
example of it's never just one
conspiracy theory and this is what we've
been talking about for a long time um i
i would have loved to have seen
from chuck grassley remember this moment
when during the 2008 presidential
campaign a woman said to john mccain
that late senator john mccain who was
the presidential candidate obama's a
muslim and he's an arab and mccain said
no he's not now i would have loved to
have seen in this clip
it's also okay to be muslim in this
country
but okay chuck grassley not exactly
living up to this standard i can't trust
obama
i i have read about him and he's not
he's not he's a
um he's an arab
he is not
no
no man no man he's a he's a he's a
decent family man citizen that i just
happen to have disagreements with on on
fundamental issues right and also
if he wasn't an arab
uh or muslim as people would say at the
time sometimes you're allowed to be
muslim and president in the united
states i mean we haven't had one okay
but you're you're you actually are
allowed to do it so chuck grassley not
not even living up to that standard but
this stuff is dangerous
and uh the republican party by and large
at least welcomes it by looking the
other way let me know your thoughts you
can find me on twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
the link is down below